مع يوم الصحه العالمي اطلقت صحيفه
الرياضيات تابعه للمجموعه السعوديه
للابحاث والنشر او مبادره رياضيه مبتكره
في السعوديه بهدف التشجيع على ممارسه
الرياضه والمبادره هي ببساطه ملاعب مطبوعه
وهذه المبادره خلت الرياضيه اول صحيفه في
العالم يمكن او يمكن ممارسه الرياضه عليها
وهذا الشيء بالتزامن مع يوم الصحه العالمي
وكما ذكرنا والتشجيع على الابتعاد عن او
عن الروتين المعتاد وممارسه النشاط البدني
كلام حلو وجميل بس اكيد كثار منكم الان
بيتسائلوا الملاعب مطبوعه كيف خلينا نشوف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ملاعب صحيفه الرياضيه المطبوعه زارها
المئات الردي ولسه متاحه امام الجميع
لاستخدامها وحقيقه يعني تحيه لزملاء في
الصحيفه على الفكره المبتكره والمبادره
المختلفه